political military and Business Leaders
got an update by video link from Kiev on
the progress of Ukraine's
counter-offensive which has been
grinding slowly but steadily along for
weeks
counter-offensive it's going not sample
once again because it's war and it's
very difficult to be sure and to
guarantee that it will be this
particularly by this speed but in
general it's going by plan your Mac was
also asked about Russia's efforts to cut
off grain exports from Ukraine by
bombarding its ports and threatening
ships that dock there it's about we need
more our defense you can see what
happened last days in Odessa and Nika
live you know I'm sure about what
happened the the grain corridors and
this is the problem not just about for
you of Ukraine it's a problem of the
world of the of the many countries and
of course we need f-16s earlier senior
U.S and European officials tried to put
a positive spin on developments the UK's
foreign minister suggested that last
month's aborted Wagner Insurrection by
yevgeny pagosian shows cracks are
appearing in the edifice of Vladimir
Putin's regime it doesn't matter how
Putin tries to spin it an attempted coup
is never a good look morale among
Russian forces is at Rock Bottom based
on intercepted phone conversations and
other data gathered by the investigative
journalism group bellingcat we see
rankenthal soldiers complaining about
lack of munition lack of food lack of
care from the commanders we see middle
range commanders complaining and we see
generals actually that walk out like
last week saying this is a disgrace we
can't continue to We Can't face our
soldiers with that lack of care that we
can afford that we can't afford to our
soldiers so morale across the board is
very low International forums like this
one here in Aspen are useful for
building consensus around critical
Global issues so far support for Ukraine
remains firm but Ukraine's continued
success on the battlefield will likely
be critical in maintaining that
consensus Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Aspen
Colorado